Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
Thank you so much for being part of my world and for listening to today's episode. Now, today's episode is all about training professionally as a psychologist when you are a parent. But please, if you are not yet a parent, please do still listen because it raises such important considerations for when you start to consider your own parenting journey. And also, if you don't want to or can't have children of your own, it helps you to think about how you might optimally support those around you within training, or even within your life generally, who have children. So it raises some really important and interesting debates. I'm joined for today's podcast by Rose Dunstan, who is a trainee clinical psychologist. And you can watch our chat on YouTube on the Good Thinking Psychological Services YouTube page, if you'd like to, but you of course don't need to
watch it if you don't want to you can just listen i need to apologize that my audio is quite quiet um in in today's podcast um i'm not quite sure why so you might just need to turn it up ever so slightly but i have adjusted the jingles so that they're a little bit quieter so they won't um suddenly deafen you um yeah i don't know what happened there but um needed to make sure that you could hear both myself and Rose throughout so I hope that you will find that okay um also need to say I only spotted when I was editing that I'd accidentally used the wrong frame on YouTube um it does say aspiring psychologist membership rather than aspiring
psychologist podcast but Rose's details are all correct and I will admit that's the only side I checked because I assumed it was right but as we all know assume makes an ass of you and me so I hope you will forgive me and not think that I am indeed an ass if you do thanks anyway for listening and still being part of my world whilst simultaneously thinking that I am an ass. That said, if you are interested in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, we have had lots of success with getting people onto training courses this year, which is just wonderful. But it does mean we've got a few spaces available um and then it's open for more members from the 1st of July so if you're interested in that then do check out um the link tree link um which gives you more details um of the membership and that can be found in the show notes or um usually at the top of all of the socials um for where you see me online um okay
I think that is everything for now and but I hope you find it a really useful episode it is a slightly longer episode than usual because there was so much to say um so yeah cozy up um you know give yourself a chunk of time because I think it is getting on for just over 50 minutes five zero so quite a lot longer than usual but all good stuff and such important personal and professional debates in psychology so this is mainly taken perhaps only taken really from a female perspective I would love to be able to have similar debates with someone who identifies as male about becoming a parent on the course or starting training you know with children or child already so if that describes you and you'd like
to come on the podcast then do please make contact with me but otherwise just you and you'd like to come on the podcast, then do please make contact with me. But otherwise, just enjoy and, you know, have an open mind if you're not yet a parent. And, you know, just really interesting conversation between myself and Rose. So hope you'll find it useful and I'll catch you again at the end. So I am joined by Rose today. Hi Rose, thank you so much for joining me. Would you like to introduce yourself? Yes, thank you so much for having me. My name is Rose Dunstan. I am a third year trainee on the Doctorate of Clinical Psychology training and I'm also the mother of a little boy who's just turned four. Oh wonderful thank you so much for
joining me and yeah like four-year-olds are bags of fun but they are also high energy and you know take a lot from you so could you tell us a little bit about your journey to psychology before we start to think about your little boy um if that's okay yeah sure so you can probably tell from my accent I wasn't born here um I was born in Australia and that's where I did my undergrad um so I did that full time um in psychology um and I also worked so I really fell on feet, I worked for a really lovely mental health charity full-time alongside my undergraduate degree and I say it was lovely because it really like had a very strong ethos for recovery. There were a lot you know so lots and lots of peer
support workers, all of my managers had like lived experience of distress and current and heard voices. And so I worked there for about four years in various roles and including at the end doing a research assistant role. And that was in a project to support voice hearers into the workplace and I think part of the other reason why I really enjoyed that role is they brought in lots of external trainers and lots of them came from the UK so they brought over like Eleanor Longdon and Rufus May, Jackie Dillon, Ron Coleman and these are sort of like lots of the names that you hear sort of in mental health or in psychosis um from this country and I guess that's sort of what drew my attention to maybe moving here. So I moved to England with my husband and it was meant to be for
a short period of time and I thought I would go home and train in Australia but then I just sort of fell in love with the country and when I, yeah so once I moved here, I had some very similar roles. I worked for a charity where I managed a high support residential service for people with, sort of inverted commas, severe and persistent mental illness. So just people with experiences of psychosis or, yeah, I guess, childhood trauma, lots of complex trauma. And I did that for quite a long time. And I sort of also managed some employment services to support people into work. And I think I got to a stage where I was, you know, just been really loving all of my jobs, I've been growing a lot. And I think I got to a stage where I was, you know, I'd just been really loving all of my jobs. I'd been growing a lot.
And I felt like my learning started to plateau. And it had always been in the back of my mind that I would apply for clinical psychology training. So I think once I realised I was going to live here forever and my learning started to plateau in these other jobs, that's when I sort of turned my sights to training. And I completed a master's here which I did alongside a full-time job and then applied for my first AP job and that was in a neurodevelopmental assessment service for children um and and then I had a child and
and I got into training so it was sort of perhaps quite a different journey to other people. I was never in a rush. It was, for me, I think I felt like I'd always end up as a clinical psychologist, but I just found myself in jobs that I just really enjoyed and I was very passionate about. I was learning a lot. So I sort of meandered my way here I guess well done to you um I was speaking to someone earlier that was saying you know I can't believe
I get paid to do this because I would actually do it for free and that's when you know that this is a career that is just a bit of you isn't it absolutely yeah although the pay helps oh the pay most definitely helps yeah I get very challenging otherwise yeah just before we start thinking about children I know that I have got people that do listen to the podcast in Australia and I know that a question I will be asked if I don't ask you is how it worked you know moving from Australia to the UK and whether you were then eligible to apply for the funded places just that sort of question if you're comfortable answering it. Yeah certainly first of all you need to like to be aware of whether your degree would be
accredited here so I think both countries are a little bit like our degrees are better than the other persons so it is you need to look into you need to make sure you have the full four-year I think both countries are a little bit like our degrees are better than the other person's. So it is something you need to look into. You need to make sure you have the full four-year degree in Australia to be able to convert it here by the BPS. For me, I have British heritage, so I already had a UK passport even before I decided to move here. So it made moving to the country quite simple. But you do need to have lived here for I think it's three years to get the residency, and that's a continuous three years. So you can't have like sort of been out of the country for too long during that period.
They're in sort of set timeframes. I think it's three years, you need to double check that. And once you're considered a resident of this country, you can apply. I think courses will look out though for, you know, they want people who are going to stay here. So they will, I think, probably look out for that a little bit, a commitment to staying and working in the NHS. Yeah. Lovely. Thank you so much for our slight deviation. But I know that that will be a question that I am asked, because it's important, isn't it, especially the variability and diversity
in our workforce. And that, you know, I do believe, and I've said before, that I've got the best job in the world. Why wouldn't someone in a different country know that and think I'd love to do that? Yeah absolutely yeah I can relate to that. So before we started recording we were speaking a little bit about your experience of applying to the doctorate, would you be okay telling us a little bit about what that was like and where baby fell in that, if that's OK? Yeah, sure. So I think I mean, one of the reasons why I guess I'm here and I guess quite passionate about this is because I agonised over the decision to have a baby. And I can't underscore that enough. it really was agony because there are these really dominant narratives I think that you can't get onto training it's incredibly hard and that having any sort of difference just makes it harder I think and having a child would mean
I guess that you might be discriminated against by courses but also that you can't get the adequate experience that you need to get onto training um and then even if you happen to get on that you can't complete training with children because it is just so incredibly challenging um and I sort of I heard that very strongly in the absolute complete absence actually of having any narratives or stories of people who had completed training with children I don't know I really felt that and yeah I was really in a place where it's like what if you know what ifs are never good are they but what if I dedicate myself to training and I finish and I am unable to have children or what if I have a
child and that means that I can never get into training um and I think because there's two very uncertain things having a child you have no idea what your life would look like with a child and then so you can't sort of plan and think how I could make that work because you don't really know. And then training, you just don't know that you're, like you don't know what the experience will be like. But also you don't know if you'll get on or when you'll get on. Will I get on when I'm 32 or 35 or 38? And what does that mean for my fertility?
So I really struggled with it. And I guess I just started applying. I applied after I had got my first AP job. And I did have the baby. And I applied before I knew that I was pregnant. So during my, when sort of the interview season came up and I was offered three interviews uh I was sort of eight months pregnant um and my son was born prematurely so
that meant that actually the day the day he was born I think I had an interview or maybe it was the day after I'm sorry obviously couldn't attend um and then um I was quite poorly after he was born and I was in hospital for a week and then I had an interview two days after I'd gotten out of hospital and um and I attended that interview and I think on reflection that seems actually ridiculous like a really um almost silly thing to do but I think again there was this narrative that like even if you get an interview this year you might not get one next year so you have to apply oh so you have to go I have to do it um and I did do it having not slept for 10 days and it didn't go well I mean well actually do you know what to be fair the interview went well but there was a written component that I just my brain just wouldn't function for um and then I had an interview about a week after that which I did attend and I and I got on a reserve list for that
one um but I actually think another probably important part of that motivation to attend is also financially so I think um I at that stage my financial situation was such that I thought I might have to work in about six months anyway and part of my rationale was well I could work as an AP and after I paid for my childcare and my travel I'll bring home about fifty dollars, sorry fifty pounds a week Or I could go back to a more demanding job which would be training but at least I'd have enough money to sort of survive on and I think that's probably I think one of the big barriers I think
to having children when you're trying to get onto the DECLIN is the cost of child care is it's just eye-wateringly high it will be almost your entire income as a band four ip um so i guess that was the process and then so i didn't get on that year and then i applied again the following year and i got two interviews and and two offers um and at that stage my son was a year old oh well well done to you and honestly you're my hero attending interviews for doctorate training whilst in the fog of being a very new mother um kudos to you and also getting a reserveless place that year like you are my hero so well done to you on that can i ask when you were applying the next year whether you you know whether you considered more family friendly courses or whether
you considered any factors around you know having your son or was it purely the traditional I like the sound of that course and you know I've met other trainees um etc um I didn't change well it's really hard to get any sort of sense of who is family friendly from the information on the clearinghouse. And in fact, I don't think any of the courses appear family friendly. I don't think it's mentioned anywhere. I've certainly never heard of courses that like invite parents to attend or speak to it in the information that they put out before you apply. So it was was sort of it was a little bit blind actually um it was more about what I thought the ethos would be um but actually having said that I then
actually attended so the two interviews that I attended um that year I actually attended one where I think they made it very clear actually it wasn't even covert they made it very clear I think that they would not support parents um to get through training or carers it there was very much sort of a spiel at the beginning um that made it clear that you you had to do this on your own and we weren't going to make adjustments for you um and my heart it was so devastating i remember i finished that interview and i walked out the door and my first thought was i did really well today i think i'm going to get an offer and my second book which i followed about two seconds later was and i cannot accept it um i just i knew that i would have a miserable time I knew that I probably wouldn't even get through it.
And then the following week I did this other interview at my training course that I'm on, and it couldn't have been a more different experience. In my interview they asked me, how are you going to, like what are your thoughts and how you might manage um being a parent and doing this this course and I could speak to that and that was fine they were placing quite warm and they sort of said that they do try to take that into account and there are some adjustments that they can made and they explained what they were and um yeah it was it was such a relief um and that of course I got the two offers
and I knew exactly where I needed to be um so it was actually very helpful really in the end but it was also you know quite heartbreaking as well thank you yeah it's so important to be treated as a human and someone that matters in this process not just a number who can be so easily replaced because you're you're a person you've got a life you know you you matter to lots of people and having you just scrape through or survive that's not what we want we want you to as much as possible thrive and really enjoy aspects of your training if not the whole thing um you know but also thrive as a mother and to have enough resources left over at the end of a day or a week to feel like you're not just utterly
exhausted and then you can be a parent as well yeah and i think also you know we there's so much talk about widening access and the importance of and i know parenting isn't a protected characteristic it is maternity is sort of for the first whilst you're pregnant and for a year after but it's not protected but I think the experience parents bring a different experience to training and there is a knowledge and an experience that can enrich sort of the knowledge of the cohort and and experiences on placement so it is valuable and I think it is important to have different people represented on cohorts.
It really is. There's a lady on my cohort who had two children. There's a few people that had children, but had two children. And, you know, I just really valued her insight. And she became sort of the mummy of our group as well you know and she was the first person I'd ever heard when she was talking about parenting her children the first person I'd ever heard to say I love you very much but I do not like that behavior and it was that separation for me that was really useful you know you're not saying I don't like the child you're
saying I don't like the behavior and so going on to a CAMHS placement with that kind of real world practical experience was really useful for me. You know, I didn't have I didn't really have many people in my life who had children. So it was a really useful resource. Like you said, this isn't you're not a burden on the cohort. You're actually a real asset. Yeah I think that too uh yeah I think you get that from everyone on the cohort like everyone brings something slightly different and it just it really enriches that I can think of so many people who are just popping to mind now who I've learned so much from from those little comments in teaching or in that small tutorial group where they've just spoken to their experience of something and it's it's planted a seed that you can draw on later um yeah I love that you're all part of a jigsaw that fits together to
enrich each other's experience definitely and as you were talking I was thinking about maybe there's room here for courses to speak to this in their you know application information about um you know becoming a parent either during training they try to dissuade that quite heavily don't they um but people it does happen you know people will have standard maternity leave within a normal fixed term contract which is training and will get um occupational maternity pay throughout training and it's quite common I think in my experience for at least a couple of people per cohort to have a baby at some point during that three-year fixed period yeah we've had quite a few people I think um in my cohort as well and it really bothers me that there is a strong message where people are dissuaded from doing that um I think
people need to be able to make decisions about their own lives and if it feels like the right time to have a child and there might be so many reasons for that that people should be supported in those decisions um I think you know as it is quite difficult to get onto training and it can take quite a long time, I think that the average age is about 28 and we're talking about often at the moment women. I don't know that people actually consider the impact on people's fertility as well.
I do know people who have had eggs frozen because they've been so worried. I know even more who have looked into it. I myself looked into it and I was put off because the cost is just so high and it's incredibly intrusive. And I think just because you want to get people through a course, like there's like this rule, like I guess throughput must be the main KPI I imagine for NHS education in England but actually yeah we're not just a number we are human beings and if people want to have families and it feels like the right time I think people need to be supported to do that and I guess it is a question that comes up a lot you'll see it on
like the AP groups and what happens if I get pregnant will I get kicked off the course there are these real like I don't I don't think people understand their employment rights that you know you are entitled to maternity leave um you are entitled to five days of carers leave a year you can apply for flexible working some courses I think would support that some probably would not but you know we are able to ask flexible working arrangements yeah thank you for clarifying that and i was trying to reflect on my experience of training um and also my knowledge of having young children and i had my children after i'd qualified but you know i know that when i was working in the nhs there would have to be some flexibility for suddenly you know you suddenly get a call on a Monday saying your child is getting the merit this weekend on Friday
can you come and you're like oh could you not have booked it a bit earlier but then suddenly you know you're due into assembly on Friday to watch them get the merit and I was trying to reflect how that would have been during training and Friday was our teaching day so there really I don't think would have been much flexibility you know they might have said I could have gone late but if it had cropped up on a placement day I think that my placement supervisors were very human so long as it wasn't going to impact too much on the day or if I was going to then work from home a little bit that evening I think it would have been supported because my placement supervisors definitely saw me as a human and they were all parents I think and I think that really helps with the context doesn't it if someone
gets the real struggles about being a parent then they're more willing to be flexible and to yeah to make a bespoke fit for you that helps you and helps the service yeah absolutely um I've also had really wonderful experiences with my supervisors they've all been incredibly supportive and in fact one wasn't a parent but I think she was quite open about that and just really curious and was like I might not understand things please explain them to me but she also I know that she went out and asked her friends who had children and asked people about different experiences of children of a similar age and I valued that so much that she actually took the time to try to to understand what my you know what my context
looks like and and some of the demands that I do have on me um so yeah really excellent experiences i i i do know that that's not universal so i've certainly spoken to people who have had a really rough time trying to negotiate even very small changes like can i work 8 30 to 4 30 instead of 9 to 5 and even when there wasn't a specific service reason why that couldn't happen it's just no we only do nine to five type responses I wonder though if that has changed that was just pre-pandemic so I do wonder if maybe COVID has helped people to think and work more flexibly and to be more okay with flexible working yeah I think um when I was newly qualified I was having to travel like 30 miles each way to get to work and it was central Birmingham which was a nightmare to get in and out of and so um there was flexibility with them allowing me to
work early and giving me a key to get into the building and giving me you know the fire safety codes um to to turn off all the alarms and things and I think if I you know because often you'll need to drop the kids at nursery at a certain time won't you and then be on your way and it just adds that bit extra time so I think do ask for flexibility because if you don't ask you don't know yeah absolutely your supervisor ex-supervisor sounds wonderfully holistic and actually really practicing what we preach with clients but actually it's really important we do that with our colleagues and with our workforce too yeah absolutely and like I said that has been my experience is generally people have been really really supportive and really understanding and alongside my placement supervisors my I think my man we call them a
manager at my training course I think places call them a clinical tutor has been really wonderful as well um really supportive and I think I was made I think before I felt like I would be seen as a burden or I'd be seen as the trainee with extra needs and that's an annoyance to people. I create extra paperwork or need more time or need more meetings or whatever, but I don't think I've ever been made to feel like that. There has been a real just sort of like, yeah, acceptance. You know, I am a person. I do have other needs and actually my role as mother is incredibly important um and people you know are practicing what they
preach um as psychologists that you know attachment and achievement and being there for your children is is crucial it really is it really is But also as a parent myself, I know some, I know it's just a mad ride. It's a mad ride. And training can feel that way as well. And then, of course, it's not just the placements. It's not just the, you know, the teaching days. There's also assignments. How have you found, you know, putting assignments around a your work life, but also your family life yeah it was much easier pre-covid so actually I think for the first six months of my course I think I managed all of them I managed things really well I went in very very organized I did a lot of planning about sort of where I would live I did relocate for the course where my son's nursery was kind of like minimize stress at the beginning and end of the day um and I worked on my assignments very
early so I was like really aware that he could get sick you know a week before an assignment is due so I just started everything early and I really made very good use of all of my time. So I think I finished my first assignment about two or three months early I you know and that was working really well and then COVID came and I actually became very ill. I got COVID sort of before the first lockdown. I got long COVID. I also have some chronic health problems and they're sort of all interacted and I became quite poorly um so I've sort of been managing that alongside as well and and what it ended up meaning is I had to really evaluate what I could do so what were my what were these balls that I have in the air and which
one's a glass and which one's a rubber and I decided that my placement was a glass ball you know I had to really do the right thing by my clients and by my services and focus on that work obviously my child my family was a glass ball and these balls that can't drop it and I guess assignments became the balls that could drop and I just had some really open conversations with my manager and all of my deadlines were moved to places that felt more manageable. So I haven't been working at the same rate as other people. I have more time to complete my assignments. It's really hard to say. That really has been framed around my health.
And I'm not sure how it would be framed if it was purely from a parenting perspective. I suspect that I would be supported to move deadlines because of parenting, maybe not to the same extent. It is quite difficult to say. So yeah, basically I haven't kept up with my assignments is the short answer I'm getting there but um do you tend to use your study days to do your assignments or is your little boy perhaps during COVID your little boy was there all the time I don't know what the agreement was
我不确定如果纯粹从为人父母的角度来看，这件事会是怎样的。我猜想，我可能会因为育儿的原因而获得宽限来推迟截止日期，但也许不会达到相同的程度。这很难说。所以，简短的回答是，基本上我没有跟上作业的进度，我正在努力赶上。不过，嗯，你倾向于用学习日来写作业吗？还是说，也许在疫情期间，你的小男孩一直都在家？我不知道你和你的幼儿园是怎么协商的
with your nursery some some just shut didn't they yes his nursery did shut um but for a few weeks for a few weeks we did this ridiculous system where like my husband and I would work between like 5 a.m and 8 p.m so we both got a full day of working and like did child care amongst it but fortunately we got him into a hub nursery um but it was you know 40 minute drive away we were doing like an hour and a half driving each per day to get him into some child care so we were very fortunate in that sense we didn't completely lose child care um so yeah i use my study days really effectively i you know it is my free time he is in child care i need to get things done and i think i think that was one of the things
关于你的幼儿园——有些直接关门了，对吧？是的，他的幼儿园确实关门了，嗯，不过有几个星期，有几个星期我们实行了一种荒唐的制度，我和我丈夫会在早上5点到晚上8点之间工作，这样我们俩都能工作一整天，并在其中穿插着照顾孩子。不过幸运的是，我们把他送进了一家中心幼儿园，但你知道的，开车要40分钟，我们俩每天各自要开一个半小时的车把他送到托儿所，所以在某种意义上我们非常幸运，我们并没有完全失去育儿托管服务。所以，是的，我非常有效地利用我的学习日。你知道的，这是我的空闲时间，他在托儿所，我需要把事情做好。我认为，这也是其中的一点，
about being a parent is that you really one of the challenges a loss of flexibility you know you can't just work whenever you want whenever suits you whenever you feel like it or you some motivation kicks in you have to work at set times you know around child care and um in some ways that's really helpful though I think it does mean that I procrastinate less. I get more things done in the blocks of time that I have because I know it will feed into my time with my son and that is huge motivation to just get things done. I don't want to be locked in an office all weekend ignoring him.
作为父母的一大挑战就是失去灵活性。你知道的，你不能想什么时候工作就什么时候工作，不能随心所欲，也不能在灵感或动力突发时才工作。你必须在固定的时间工作，围绕着育儿安排来展开。嗯，在某些方面这其实真的很有帮助，我认为这确实意味着我更少拖延了。在我拥有的有限时间里，我能完成更多的事情，因为我知道这些时间会融入我和儿子相处的时间里，这成了把事情做完的巨大动力。我不想整个周末都被锁在办公室里不理他。
I want to spend my weekends with him. So there are pros and cons to it definitely definitely um is there anything that i haven't asked you that you think would be useful for us to talk about or anything to add in any of the areas that we've spoken about i guess maybe we could speak a little bit through maybe some of the like the pros and cons of of parenting i don't know if that might help during the decline it might maybe bring it to life a little bit for people um who are thinking about having a child yeah so i think maybe please do yes i guess maybe for me i think the pros there are so many pros
我想把周末留给他。所以这其中肯定有利也有弊。嗯，有没有什么我还没问过你，但你觉得对我们讨论很有用的事情？或者在我们谈论过的任何领域中有什么想补充的吗？我想，也许我们可以稍微聊聊为人父母的一些利弊。我不知道这对于那些正在考虑要孩子的人来说，会不会在他们情绪低落时有所帮助，让他们对这种生活有更直观的感受？是的，所以我认为，请说吧，好吗？我想，对我来说，我觉得利有很多，
that that are sort of i never envisaged and i think one of them is just how much joy that is brought into my life from having a child um and the love and to you know be met with cuddles and have someone in your life who's just so happy to see you um it's really nice and I think how play forces you to be very mindful and very present it pulls you away from your worries I spend a lot of time stomping in puddles and looking at aeroplanes and animals and flowers. And I just think it's really good for my mental health and it's really good to pull me away from the stresses of the doctorate perhaps.
这些好处是我以前从未预料到的。我想其中之一就是，生一个孩子给我的生活带来了多少快乐；还有那种爱，你知道的，迎面而来的拥抱，生活里有一个总是那么高兴见到你的人——这真的很好。而且我认为，游戏会迫使你变得非常专注、活在当下，它把你从忧虑中拉出来。我花了很多时间在水坑里踩水，看飞机、动物和鲜花。我只是觉得这对手术心理健康真的很好，而且能很好地把我从博士学业的压力中拉出来。
I guess I've already spoken a bit about time management and how that helps me there. But I think maybe also it really brings theories to life for me. So, for instance, attachment theory, I've always, it's not that complicated to understand, but I think when you have it right in front of you, it sort of, you know, you can see like what achievement looks like. This is, I'm attuned to my child right now.
我想我已经稍微谈过时间管理以及它是如何在这方面帮助我的。但我也觉得，它确实让各种理论在我面前变得生动起来。所以，比如依恋理论，我一直都觉得——它理解起来并不算太复杂，但当你把它直接摆在面前时，它就会让你看到，你知道的，成就感是什么样子的。这就是：“我此刻正与我的孩子同频共振。”
And you can see how like separation anxiety and things play out It brings like developmental Psychology to life it you know, I always forget like the milestone in the stages and now I don't they're right there in front of me And perhaps it helps me a little bit with Placement, but you know working with families I remember when I worked in the neurodevelopmental assessment service always being like quite puzzled why parents couldn't remember milestones like when did your child first speak through the night they had no idea or when they uttered their first word and so like how do you not know this it's like
你可以看到分离焦虑之类的事情是如何表现出来的。它让发展心理学变得生动起来。你知道的，我总是忘记里程碑和各个阶段，但现在不会了，它们就摆在我面前。也许它对我的实习也有点帮助，你知道的，在与家庭打交道时，我记得当我在神经发育评估服务机构工作时，总是对父母为什么记不清里程碑感到很困惑，比如你的孩子第一次整夜睡觉是什么时候？他们完全不知道。或者他们说出第一个词是什么时候？所以，你当时就会想：怎么会有人不知道这些？这就好比，
well now I know why they don't know this. Very, a lot happens in that time. It's perhaps appropriate for me to now disclose that the tooth fairy did forget to come in our house last night. Like, you know, it matters very much at that moment. But then a split second later, you're on to doing something else and you just forget. And yeah, sometimes you do drop those balls. And I love the idea of your rubber balls and glass balls I hadn't heard of that before but I'm going to keep that but yeah I'm hoping that the tooth fairy doesn't turn out to be a glass ball and that's we're going to be able to repair that
好吧，现在我知道他们为什么不知道了。那段时间发生的事情太多了。现在向大家坦白可能正合适，昨晚牙仙子确实忘记来我们家了。就像，你知道的，那一刻这非常重要。但紧接着在几分之一秒后，你就要去做别的事了，然后你就全忘了。是的，有时候你确实会把那些球掉在地上。我非常喜欢你提到的“橡胶球和玻璃球”的比喻，我以前没听过，但我会记住这个说法的。不过，是的，我希望牙仙子不要变成一个玻璃球，我们今晚将能够修复这个裂痕，
rupture this evening ongoing consequences for forgetting but it is this it's like the fallibility of parents and I think when you're like camps, maybe, and you're thinking about homework tasks that parents are supporting children with, really being able to hold in mind what everyone's experience is obviously different, but having an idea of some of the demands that might be on that parent and why they might not be able to support that child with that task. You know, and it's like all those things. You don't need an experience to understand it but i think it
不用承担遗忘带来的长远后果。但这就是父母的易错性。我想，当你身处训练营，或者考虑父母如何协助孩子完成家庭作业时，你真的能够铭记在心：每个人的经历显然都是不同的，但对那位父母可能面临的一些要求有所了解，就能明白为什么他们可能无法协助孩子完成那项任务。你知道的，就是所有这些事情。你不需要亲身经历就能理解它，但我认为它
certainly helps perhaps um so there's some of the positives and i definitely you know some of the we do this thing when we go to bed each one i'm not going to bed my kids are what's the favorite part of your day and what was the least favorite part of the day and the kids both do theirs and then they'll ask me um and sometimes they all say what's the funniest part of your day and you're like oh god i really didn't have a very funny day today you know but it does force you to look for that gratitude you know and to look for the things that we could make different tomorrow and the things we could strive to do better better um or in a different way and i really love that you know um just some of my joyful moments will be when my little boys like really in my face and the other
确实会有所帮助。所以，这些是一些积极的方面。而且我绝对——你知道的，我们有个习惯，每当我们去睡觉时——我不是要去睡觉，是我的孩子们——我们会问：“你今天最喜欢的部分是什么？你今天最不喜欢的部分是什么？”两个孩子都会说出自己的回答，然后他们会问我。有时候他们会问：“你今天最搞笑的部分是什么？”然后你就会想：“天哪，我今天真的没有什么很搞笑的事。”你知道的，但这确实会迫使你去寻找那种感激之情，去寻找我们明天可以做得不同的地方，以及我们努力做得更好、或者以不同方式去做的那些事情。我真的很喜欢这一点，你知道的，
day we were talking about teeth and how white my little boy's like really in my face and the other day we were talking about teeth and how white my little boy's teeth are because they're like super white aren't they and he goes mummy you've got beautiful golden teeth and I'm like oh you know they think they're being really nice actually like we basically say and I've got yellow teeth thanks kid but you know just adorable adorable love and you know like you said they're so pleased to see you make a cheer when you walk through the door yeah I basically do have a little cheerleader who follows I love your jumper mummy you are so kind you're my favorite person I love you like you know it's wonderful absolutely oh oh they do grow up they do grow up but um I've got two boys and they're both still very cuddly at the age of eight and almost six.
我的某些快乐时刻就是我的小男孩非常贴近我的时候。前几天我们在谈论牙齿，以及我小男孩的牙齿有多白，因为它们超级白，对吧？然后他说：“妈妈，你有一口漂亮的黄金牙齿。”然后我就想，哦……你知道的，他们以为自己在说好听的话。实际上，我们基本上可以说：“我有黄牙，谢谢你，孩子。”但你知道的，就是那种可爱至极的爱。就像你说的，他们见到你时是那么高兴，你走进门时他们会欢呼。是的，我基本上确实有一个跟屁虫啦啦队队员：“妈妈，我喜欢你的毛衣，你太好了，你是我最喜欢的人，我爱你。”你知道的，这太棒了！哦，哦，他们确实会长大，他们确实会长大。不过，我有两个男孩，他们到八岁和快六岁的时候依然很爱粘人、喜欢拥抱。
They're adorable. But it is tricky. It's not all a bed of roses. Should we perhaps think about some of the difficult patches of parenting? I will just chuck in there the concept of sleep. And I'm just gonna let you get on with that well actually before I jump on that could I add one more positive because I think it's one that slipped my mind but I think of course you can and I think it's my mind because it's the absence of something and I think for me it's the absence of the distress I was feeling about not being a parent yet and this is this sense of like my life will start after my life was after I get on to training or my life was after I qualify and sort of always waiting for the future to have the
他们太可爱了。但这确实很棘手，生活并非全是玫瑰园。我们是不是该考虑一下育儿过程中一些艰难的时期？我在这里顺便提一下“睡眠”这个概念，然后我就不打扰你了，让你接着说。不过，实际上，在我插话之前，我能再补充一个积极的方面吗？因为我觉得这是一个差点被我遗漏的方面，但我觉得——当然可以。我觉得它从我脑海中滑落是因为它是一种“缺失”，而对我来说，这是那种我不再因为自己还不是父母而感到痛苦的缺失。这种感觉就像：“我的生活要等到……我的生活要等到我开始接受培训之后才会开始”或者“我的生活要等到我获得资格认证之后才会开始”，总是为了未来的生活去等待你想要的东西。我觉得我不再经历那种痛苦了，而那曾是非常消耗精力的。所以我想，我现在既有了孩子，又在接受培训，我某种程度上算得上是鱼与熊掌兼得了。嗯，对我来说，这可能真的是最大的积极方面。
things that you want and I think I don't experience that distress anymore and it was very consuming so I think I have a child and I'm on training I've sort of got my cake and I got to eat it too and um and that for me is probably the biggest positive actually that's so important thank you so much for for including that it is it's exhausting when you're trying to make a decision isn't it and it can consume all of your thoughts um so yeah it's really important and like you said you know it probably can take an average from graduating undergrad to starting clinical training about seven or eight years but that places you at least 28 27 you know 29 maybe and like you said that really is a key window in infertility
这太重要了，非常感谢你把它包含在内。当你试图做出决定时，这真的很令人筋疲力尽，不是吗？它会消耗你所有的想法。所以，是的，这真的很重要。就像你说的，从本科毕业到开始临床培训，平均可能需要七到八年的时间，这会让你处于至少28岁、27岁，或者29岁的年纪。正如你所说，这确实是人们生育能力的一个关键窗口期，所以这是一件大事。在这次采访之前，我其实并没有怎么想过这件事。我开始课程时其实是单身，在第二年第二周遇到了伴侣，所以，你知道的，我们熬过了那段日子，然后结了婚，大约一年后有了一个宝宝。但如果我在那之前几年遇到他，在培训期间生一个孩子很可能就是对的时机。是的，我确实希望通过这些对话，人们能够更多地把这件事记在心里，或者……因为我能理解为什么人们不会去想这件事。所以希望，是的，这只是一个可以开始被更多讨论的话题。是的，我觉得这真的很重要。我们是不是该想想
journeys for for people and so it is a big deal um it's not really something I'd thought about until until this interview um I started the course single actually um and met my partner in the second week of the second year and so you know we got through it and then got married and then had a baby like a year later but if I'd met him a few years before then it might well have been the right time to have a child during training yeah I sort of do hope that by having these conversations it's something that people might hold in mind a little bit more or because I can see why people wouldn't think about that so hopefully yeah it's just sort of a discussion that can start being had a little bit more yeah I think it's really important should we think about some
一些——一些——一些缺点，或者一些负面因素？是的，那些棘手的部分，没错。我的意思是，睡眠是一个大问题，对吧？我很幸运，我的孩子睡眠相当不错。但你知道的，这并不稳定。我想，甚至在我所有的计划中，最让我感到震惊的是，我并不知道当小孩子第一次去幼儿园时，他们基本上需要建立一个免疫系统。所以他对一切都没有免疫力。在前六个月里，我毫不夸张地说，
of the some of the some of the drawbacks or some of the negative yeah the tricky parts exactly that i mean sleep is a big one isn't it i i'm quite lucky in that i have had a child who does sleep quite well um but you know it's not consistent and I think maybe the thing that struck me the most, even in all of my planning, I was not aware that when small children attend nursery for the first time, they basically need to develop an immune system. So he was immune to nothing. And for the first six months, I'm not exaggerating when I say
他要么每星期感冒一次，要么每两星期感冒一次，他总是生病。虽然都是些小病，但这意味着当他生病时会打乱他的睡眠，他可能会变得有点烦躁。而且，我自己的免疫系统也不是最好的，所以我可能把他得的每一次感冒都传染上了，因此我也连续六个月一直在生病。同样，这些都是比较轻微的病，我想有一两次发展成了感染。但你知道的，生病这么长时间真的让人筋疲力尽。如果没有一个让他们整晚睡不觉的咳嗽，育儿就已经够难了，你知道吗？哦天哪，还有那恶心的咽反射，他一咳嗽就呕吐，然后就哭，这种情况经常发生，
he got a cold either every week or every second week he was always sick um and there were minor illnesses um but what it does mean is when you see it disrupts his sleep he can be just a little bit miserable um but also i don't have the best immune system so i was probably picked up every second cold that he had so I was also perpetually sick for six months um and again they were quite low level I think one or two developed into infections but you know but it is exhausting to sort of be unwell for such a long period of time parenting is hard enough without a cough that keeps them awake all night you know oh my gosh and and no like the gag reflex he coughs and he vomits and then he cries and that happens a lot
有大量的深夜洗衣服和深夜洗澡。我觉得孩子们就是太不可预测了，不是吗？因为除了生病，还有其他各种事情会突然冒出来：他们会经历不同的发育阶段，会经历睡眠倒退，而这一切发生时你毫无防备。而且永远没有一个好时机，你知道的，人们会说：“发生这种事真不是时候。”在你的培训期间，永远没有一个好时机让你的孩子出问题。总会有临床工作、重要的教学、那个重要的MRP会议或者别的事情。所以这就是这种不断的平衡 juggling（兼顾）。这背后有着真正的认知工作负荷和情感工作负荷，你必须不断地
there's a lot of like late night laundry um and late night baths um i think just children are just so unpredictable aren't they because there's the illness but there's just other things crop up there they go through different state developmental stages they go through sleep regressions um and it just happens when you you don't expect it and there is never a good time you know people like oh it was a bad time for that to happen there is never a good time in your training for something to go wrong with your child there will always be clinical work or important teaching or that important MRP meeting or something um so it's just this constant juggling there's a real um cognitive workload and an emotional workload that sort of goes with that you're constantly
重新调整你的日程安排和优先级，不得不向人们解释事情并重新安排时间，你知道的，这真的会让人筋疲力尽。我想对我来说，在育儿托管方面曾有过非常大的问题。所以，即使他在整个疫情期间都能留在托儿所里，我不知道人们是否意识到，早期教育行业受到了巨大的冲击。疫情和英国脱欧意味着大量员工流失。有很多空缺职位，对我来说这意味着托儿所会经常关闭活动室。
rejuggling your schedule and your priorities and having to explain things to people and reschedule things and you know it can be really exhausting um i think for me there have been huge there have been quite big issues with child care so even even that he could stay in child care um throughout covid i don't know if people are aware there's been a huge impact on the early years sector. COVID and Brexit has meant a mass loss of staff. There are lots of vacancies, and for me that means that they have room closures really often.
所以可能有一段时间，托儿所每周或每两周就会关闭一天，而我面临着无人照看孩子的困境。我很幸运，我丈夫的工作非常灵活，所以当这种情况发生时，他会把孩子接走。我想其他人可能会有可以支持他们的大家庭，但我觉得要意识到育儿托管并不像你想象的那么稳定。同样，这只是最后关头的焦头烂额：让我们改变优先级吧。在你的周围，你是否能够建立起一个妈妈或育儿社交网络？因为我知道你的父母可能在澳大利亚，而如果身边没有家人，要抚养我的孩子，对我来说会非常非常棘手。你在这方面情况如何？
So probably there's been a period where nursery will just close for a day a week or every second week and I'm left with no childcare and I'm very fortunate my husband has a very flexible job so he he picks that up when that happens and I guess other people might have wider family who could support them but I think being aware that childcare isn't as consistent as you might think it is um and again that's just a last minute juggle let's um change our priorities have you been able to form much of a mummy or parenting network around you because i know that your parents are likely in australia and the idea of raising my children without um you know family around would be very very tricky for me how's that been for you it has been very
情况非常、非常棘手。所以，是的，我在英格兰没有任何直系亲属，甚至我的远亲也很远。我丈夫也没有，所以真的只有我们俩。而且因为我为了这门课程搬了家，我也离开了我的妈妈互助小组。我离开了一些非常要好的朋友，他们曾是我在最后关头寻求支持的人。甚至在整个疫情期间，你知道的，我们没有社交气泡。真的只有我们俩和我们的儿子。所以，不，没有我可以随时打电话求助的人。因此，在大流行期间，曾有那么一段时间我们在隔离，我儿子的体温非常高，我们的退烧药（Calpol）快用完了，周围商店的货源也短缺。我就想：我买不到退烧药，我没有任何可以打电话叫他帮我把退烧药带来的人。
very tricky um so yeah I don't have any immediate family in England um and even my extended family are far away um and neither does my husband so it really is just the two of us um and because I relocated from the course I also moved away from my mother's group. I moved away from some very close friends who were the people that I relied on last minute for support. And then even throughout COVID, you know, we didn't have a bubble. It was literally just the two of us with our son. So, no, there aren't people I can call on last minute. So I kind of during the pandemic, there was a time where we were isolating my son had a really high temperature we were nearly out of cow pole there was a shortage in the shops around us and I was like I cannot get cow pole I can have no one I can call
那真的很难。所以，我不知道我是否会推荐这种做法。我认为需要仔细考虑搬迁、你住的地方以及你周围都是谁，因为身边有人支持真的非常重要。我想在我的脑海里，我以为搬家后我能够建立起这些联系。但随之而来的当然是大流行，我无法融入我的社区，我无法结交那些朋友。所以我想我直到现在才刚刚开始这样做。我可以说，你目前虽然还没有，但我根据自己融入小学的经验来看，我真心希望你很快就会拥有这一切。所以，我现在是四年级家长群和一年级家长群的一员，
who can bring me cow pole and it was so it was really hard um so I don't know that I'd recommend that I think thinking carefully about relocation and where you live and who is around you, because having people around is really important. And I think in my mind, I thought I'd be able to make those links after I moved. But then of course the pandemic happened and I couldn't embed myself in my community I couldn't um make those friends so I guess I'm only just starting to do that now I would say you haven't got that currently but my experience of you know being in a primary school is that I really hope you'll have that soon um so I am part of a year four group and a year one group um which is
这其实是一个生日派对之后自然形成的。当时有人在WhatsApp上为妈妈们建立了一个生日派对名单，在那之后我们决定都留在群里，这简直太宝贵了。还有校门口的闲聊之类的，自从他们进入同一所学校、从学前班开始就非常有用。说实话，我真的结交到了朋友，在疫情期间也是如此，会有人问：“你需要什么吗？如果有人生病了，我会顺便给你送过去。我会做这个，我去商店，我反正也要去。”还有所有这些学校组织的募捐活动，哦，我们要往乌克兰送物资。当时我正因肠胃炎病倒在家，我就想：我没办法去超市。然后另一个人就说：“我来给你买尿不湿，
kind of it formed off the back of a birthday party actually someone had put together a birthday party list for the mums on whatsapp and after that we decided to just all stay on it and it's been invaluable and also chats at the school gates and stuff has been really useful from preschool onwards that they've been in the same school but um I have honestly made friends and people that definitely you know during COVID as well do you need anything if people have been ill I'll drop it around to you you know I'll do this I'll go to the shops I'm going anyway and then all these like school collections that happen oh we're going to send stuff to the Ukraine and I was um off sick with um a sickness bug and I was like I can't get to the supermarket and someone else was well, I'll buy nappies for you.
我会把它顺便带到学校，你通过PayPal把钱转给我就行。”事实上，抚养一个孩子确实需要一个社区的力量。我个人发现，我在其他学校家长那里真正建立了一个重要的社区，甚至不仅仅是妈妈们，还有一些爸爸在其中也起到了非常重要的作用。所以，我真的希望随着你的小男孩即将开始上学，你也会拥有其中的一部分，并且能够为自己找到一些真正支持你的部落成员。谢谢你，这也是我的希望。我想我们才刚刚开始接触学前教育，现在托儿所是第一次重新开放，我们刚刚被允许重新进去，你已经可以隐约感受到那些不同了。所以，是的，这就是我的希望，那将是美妙的。
And I'll drop them into school and just ping me the money on PayPal. And actually, it does take a community to raise a child. And I personally have found that I've really built an important community in the other school parents, not even just the mums. There's dads that have been really important in that as well. So I really hope that with your little boy about to start school that you'll have some of that and you'll find some really supportive tribe members yourself thank you that is my hope as well and I guess we're just starting to do a little bit with preschool and now that like the room is like the nursery is just open for the first time we just allowed back in and you can already sort of feel those differences um so yeah that is that is my hope it would be wonderful
嗯，我想我可能还想稍微谈谈的另一件事是，带着孩子继续学业培训，是我没有预料到的——我感觉自己有多么不同，而且最初这感觉是一个非常、非常孤独的境地。我真的没有预料到这一点，因为我觉得在我的生活中，我周围一直都是父母。在我的本科阶段，我有带着孩子的成熟朋友；在我所有的工作中，周围也总是有身为父母的人——对不起，我的硕士阶段、到处都是。
um I guess one other thing that perhaps I wanted to speak to a little bit is I think that I hadn't anticipated going on to training with a child is actually how different I felt and how it felt a very very lonely place to be I think initially and I really didn't anticipate it because I think for my life I've always been around parents. In my undergrad I had friends with children. In all of my work I've always been people with parents, who were parents, sorry, my masters, everywhere.
然后你进入了培训阶段，这里就像是没有父母存在一样。我的同届学员规模非常大，我想有44人，而其中只有另一位父母。44个人里面只有这么一个，有她在身边是极其宝贵的。不过，她的孩子要大得多，所以其中仍然存在差异。进入那个环境后，嗯……我想我感到非常孤独，我感到非常孤独，也觉得非常不被理解。而且，我身份认同中的很大一部分，也许并没有受到邀请，或者并没有——是的，也许并没有被包容进去。
And then you sort of get onto training and it's just sort of like there are no parents here. I had a very large cohort of I think 44 and there was one other parent um but just one amongst 44 and having her was invaluable I think um however her children were a lot older so there are still differences there and I think going into that space and uh I just I think I felt very alone um and I think I felt very alone and I think I felt very misunderstood. And, like, there was a huge part of my identity that maybe I wasn't invited or wasn't, yeah, included perhaps.
而且，你知道的，我同届的每个人，他们都是可爱的人。我爱我同届的每一个人，这无关具体的人。我认为这只关乎临床培训项目的定位和构建方式。你知道的，当大家出去聚会时，你不能总是跟着去，因为你有其他的责任；或者如果大家打算在周末去野餐，你会觉得：“嗯，我觉得我没办法去。”是的，我真的没有为此做好准备。
And that's, you know, everyone on my cohort, they're lovely people. I love everyone on my cohort. It wasn't, it's not about individual people. I think it is just about the way that the declin is positioned and framed. And, you know, not being able to always go out for drinks when people go out because you have other responsibilities or if people are going, you know, having a picnic on the weekend, being like, well, I don't think I can make that work. And, yeah, I really wasn't prepared for that.
所以，但是我认为，这里面有一种关于“接纳并拥有你的身份”的事情。我想如果我对此更有自信，我本可以展现出更多真实的自我，本可以感觉更真实，本可以不那么孤独。所以这绝对是一个挑战。我认为如果人们对自己的这种身份更加自信，这是完全可以克服的。这非常重要。我能想象到那场野餐，你知道的，他们可能会说：“哦，你可以带着他一起去。”但同时，如果你和幼儿一起去过野餐，你就会把大部分时间花在去看鸭子、去田野的远角看各种东西上。
So, but I think there is something about owning your position and I think if I were more confident in that, I could have brought more of myself and I could have felt more authentic and I could have felt less lonely. So it's certainly a challenge. I think it is something that can be overcome if people are sort of more confident in in that position it's very important and I'm imagining that picnic you know they might have said oh you could bring him along but also having been on a picnic with young
那将不会是放松的，对你来说也不会是丰富充实的，因为其他所有人都在度过美好的时光，而你却不得不走开，去做点别的事情。所以，你并不总是能够把这两者完美地交织融合在一起。是的，这倒也是。不过我想，难说，你会找到那些能够让你做到这一点的朋友。你会找到那个愿意陪你一起散步、陪你看鸭子的朋友，或者那些愿意过来高高兴兴地坐在你的浴室里陪着你，一边看你给孩子洗澡一边聊天，或者陪你在厨房做饭的朋友。我觉得关键在于找到属于你的人。不过也许，你说得也太对了，真的。我的——
children you would spend most of your time going and looking at the ducks and you know going and going and looking at things in the far corner of the field. And that would not be relaxing and it wouldn't be enriching for you because everyone else would be having a lovely time and you'd just be off, you know, doing something different. And so it's not always that you can, you know, enmesh the two. Yeah, that's true. Although I think, I don't know, you'll just find people though who enable you to do that you'll find the
我丈夫在我们小男孩（当时我们唯一的孩子）的一岁生日那天开始了一份新工作。我当时对此真的很沮丧，因为他有一整周都不能参加培训。但正是我的同届学员中的一位来看望了我，
friend who will walk with and look at the ducks with you or you know the friends who can come over and happily sit with you in your bathroom while you bathe your child and chat or while you're cooking dinner and I think it's about finding your people but maybe it's also you're so right actually yeah my um my husband started a new job on our little boys, our only child at the time, his first birthday. And I was just really upset about that because he was off training for like a whole week. But it was a member of my cohort who came around
并且做了那样的事——帮孩子洗澡，和我一起吃蛋糕，你知道的，还给他买了一个小礼物。而且，你知道的，即使他们没有孩子，你在培训期间也绝对可以找到你的部落。她当时也没有孩子。所以，是的，我认为这是一个非常、非常站得住脚的观点，谢谢你提出来，罗斯。是的，也许正在听节目的、尚未成为父母的人，如果你们今年也要参加培训，这或许可以成为你们思考的一个方向：也许你们可以主动去寻找身为父母的同学，也许你们可以邀请有孩子的同学去野餐，
and did exactly that, did a bath, did cake with me. And, you know, bought him a little present. And, you know, you absolutely can find your tribe during training as well even if they don't have parents she didn't have parents didn't have children at the time um so yeah i think that's a really a really valid point so thank you for making it rose yeah and maybe people who are listening who aren't yet parents but maybe if you you end up on training this year like maybe it could be something that you think about like maybe you could seek out the parent maybe you could invite the parent to the picnic
去和他们一起看鸭子，或者邀请他们去酒吧（如果带着非常小的婴儿的话，去酒吧可能会更容易一些）。但也许人们可以把这一点记在心里，那会很不错的。真的会很不错，真的会很不错。感觉我可以跟你聊上一整天，因为这里面有太多的内容。感觉我们需要为所有这些因素专门做一个加长版特辑，因为有太多、太多的重要内容了。我只是想对你的大学表达由衷的感谢，感谢他们允许你今天如此公开地畅所欲言，因为这是一场极其宝贵的对话。
and go and look at the ducks with them and maybe or invite them to the pub which is easier if you have a very small child baby but maybe people could hold that in mind a little bit that would be nice um it really would it really would it feels like i could talk to you all day because there's so much of this it feels like we need to do like a special extended edition for all these factors because there's so much um so much important stuff um i just wanted to say a big thank you to um your your your university for allowing you to come and speak so openly today because it's it's an invaluable conversation to have yeah yeah thank you so much for having me I have really enjoyed doing it um yeah and I am very grateful to my university and I don't know that I've sort of I did give you
对，对，非常感谢邀请我来，我真的很享受这次经历。是的，我非常感激我的大学。我不知道我是否——我确实给了你今天发言的许可，但我与他们的经历非常愉快，他们一直非常、非常支持我。嗯，我想我会真正鼓励人们非常仔细地考虑他们申请的是哪门课程，在面试时这是否让他们觉得适合自己。我认为确实存在一种真正的压力，就像“如果我拿到录取通知书，我就必须接受它”。但其实需要认真思考的是：这些人、这个课程会支持我顺利度过它，
permission to speak today but and I am I have had a really good experience with them they have been very very supportive and um yeah I guess I would really encourage people to think very carefully about what course they do apply to and if at interview if it does feel right for them. And I think there's a real pressure just like if I get an offer, I just have to accept it. But just really thinking about like will these people, will this course support me to get through
让我能拥有合理的时间，并且在面对培训的巨大要求的同时，他们也会支持我成为我想象中的那样一个合格的父母吗？绝对是的。非常感谢你今天抽出时间，罗斯。我祝愿你顺利完成论文、完成最后的临床实习，当然，在这一切结束后找到满意的工作，同时也祝愿你的育儿之旅以及你可能想要的任何未来的孩子一切顺利。我希望你在你想做的任何事情上都能做得很出色。非常感谢！是的，也谢谢你邀请我来这里，开启这场对话。我希望未来能有更多这样的对话。
it so that I have a reasonable time and will they support me to be able to be the parent that I want to be as well alongside these you know the big demands of training definitely definitely thank you so much for your time today Rose and I'd like to wish you all the very best with completing your thesis completing your final placement and of course finding employment once all of this is over but also you know with your parenting journey and any future children that you might want to have as well. I hope that you you know hope that you do really well in whatever it is you want to do. Thank you so much yeah and thank you for yeah inviting me here and yeah for opening up conversation. And I hope more conversations are had in the future.
非常感谢。我们是通过Instagram上的一次聊天建立联系的，对吧？非常感谢你如此慷慨地抽出时间，同我们聊聊这些非常重要的因素。祝你一切顺利。谢谢。非常感谢大家的收听。与罗斯交谈是一件非常愉快的事。是的，我希望你觉得这很有用，并能引起你的共鸣——无论是因为你本身就是父母，或者你身边有一些身为父母的朋友，又或者，你知道的，这会对你未来自己的培训之旅有所帮助（无论是准备成为父母，还是在带着孩子的情况下开始培训，或者是为了更好地支持和包容你未来同届学员中的父母）。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。
Thank you so much. It was through a chat on Instagram, I think, wasn't it, that we connected. But thank you so much for being so generous with your time and talking with us about these really important factors. I'm wishing you all the best. Thank you. Thank you so much for listening. It has been such a pleasure to chat with Rose. And yeah, I hope that you have found it useful and it's resonated with you, either because you are a parent or you perhaps know some people who are parents or maybe, you know, this will be useful for your own training journey ahead, either to become a parent or to start training when you've got children or to help optimally support and include any parents on your future cohort. Thank you so much for being part of my world.
请花一点时间在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上给这个节目或整个播客评分并留下评价。你只需一直滚动到节目页面的最底部，就在第一集和预告片集下方，然后你就会看到评分和评价板块。做这件事只需要花你一会儿时间，但对我的帮助却极其巨大，它能向大家证明我们在本播客中所做的事情真的很重要、也非常有用。如果你真的很喜欢这个播客，你也可以进行捐赠来帮助承担运营成本，相关详情可以在节目文稿（show notes）的 Linktree 链接中找到。节目文稿中还附有罗斯的临床相关……
Please do take a moment to rate and review this show or this podcast more generally on the Apple podcast, which you can do by scrolling right down to the bottom of the show, right below episode one and below the trailer episode. And then you will spot the rate and review section. To do that takes you a moment, but helps me so much to help demonstrate that what we do in this podcast really matters and is really useful if you really really like the podcast you can also make a donation to help cover the costs and the details of that are in my link tree in the show notes there are details in the show notes as well of Rose's clinical um but I do believe that um it is entirely possible um to successfully have children on other courses too so um let's not massively stack out their applications next
但我相信，在其他课程中成功生养孩子也完全是可能的。所以，如果你们是父母，明年就不要给他们的申请造成过大的堆积压力啦。不过，是的，无论你在哪里，都祝你一切顺利，对自己好一点，保重。如果你正朝着成为一名心理学家的道路迈进，那就让本播客成为你的指南吧。有这个播客伴你左右，你将顺利走上获得专业资质的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）主持的《有抱负的心理学家》（The Aspiring Psychologist）。
year if you are a parent um but yeah wishing you well wherever you are and stay kind to yourself take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the
我叫杰娜（Jana），是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往这一职业有如此之多的不同途径，成为心理学家并没有什么完美的既定方式。这让我充满了信心，让我知道我并没有走错路，也减少了给自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。
different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。